hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one key theme that runs throughout
Rainer Maria Rilke is letters to a young
poet is the relationship between art on
the one hand and criticism of art on the
other hand now if you're thinking
criticism is always derogatory or
negation allure something like that he
doesn't actually mean that what he's
talking about is something that we're
you know much more familiar with in
terms of other things you know movies
albums that come out other music
criticism can mean saying something is
good saying it's bad saying why that's
the case it involves judgment
so it's judgements upon art rather than
being art itself and why do we indeed
have criticism at all
well you know it's in part because
that's the way we publicize and call
attention to and have conversations
about art otherwise art might linger by
itself over in the corner and criticism
encompasses a lot later on he's going to
talk about journalism about criticism
per se about literature in which
sometimes criticism will be embedded we
might talk about philosophy of art and
beauty we could talk about all sorts of
things
Rilke himself is rather
down on criticism he thinks that it
doesn't really reach art in what art is
when it's good art in this he would be
differing from other people who are
talking about art and it's it's related
topics like for example Oscar Wilde who
defends the notion that criticism
literary criticism artistic criticism
could itself be creative in kind
Rilke is going to take the opposite
position and it's there in the very
first letter to kompis he says nothing
touches a work of art so little as words
of criticism they always result in more
or less fortunate misunderstandings so
criticism by itself is already a
misunderstanding of the work of art and
this would also apply to say criticism
of one's way of living or approaching
things if those can be understood
artistically now he goes on and he says
you're asking me mister coppice whether
your verses are any good and I would
like you to stop doing that and other
things what are the other things you're
comparing them with other poems you're
sending them to magazines you're getting
upset when editors reject your work
please stop doing that sort of thing why
is it Rilke saying because that brings
you down and I don't like having a
correspondence with somebody who's not
happy happy all the time no it's because
by focusing on that you're taking the
focus away from where it ought to be he
says nobody can advise or help you
here's what you need to do go into
yourself find out the reason that
commands you to write see whether it's
spread its roots into the very depths of
your heart confess to yourself whether
you would have to die if you were
forbidden to write and you know the in
essence think about how important how
central artistic creation is to you if
it's not that important stop doing it
and do something else and you can have a
perfectly good life doing that if it is
something that you have to do then do it
he says if out of this turning within
under this immersion in your own world
poems come you will not think of asking
anyone whether they are good or not nor
will you try to interest magazines in
these works why you will see them as
your dear natural possession a piece of
your life a voice from it and here's
where he has a very wonderful phrase a
work of art is good if it is arisen out
of necessity that is the only way one
can judge it Rilke says if it is arisen
out of necessity the necessity of the
artist him or herself needing to create
and not just to create or to express
themselves but to create this to do this
that is what makes a piece of art truly
valuable
according to Rilke a little bit later he
talks about how criticism is really
unsuited to reach art where it is he
says for this reason read as little as
possible of literary criticism why
because literary criticism is one of two
things
it's either partisan opinions he says
which have become petrified and
meaningless hardened and empty of life
so they don't have the liveliness of the
work of art which you can have a direct
relationship to either they become mad
or they are merely clever word games and
he says in which case one wins and
tomorrow the opposite view wins that's
not useful either so we don't want some
ossified classification systems and we
don't want clever word games jockeying
for a position in the art world or
anything along those lines what do we
want instead what can we use in order to
grasp art he says works of art are of an
infinite solitude I Nizam kite in German
this is a central concept for Rilke in
letters to a young poet no means of
approach is so useless as criticism
because they don't get into the work of
art what then allows us to get into a
work of art he said
love only love can touch and hold them
and be fair to them always trust
yourself and your own feeling as opposed
to argumentation discussions or
introductions of that sort if it turns
out that you're wrong you go and you see
an artwork and you respond to it and you
have your feeling response to it an
effective response which by the way
doesn't mean that it doesn't have any
articulation and thought or words or
anything like that feelings are not mute
they take shape through words and
through actions it turns out that you're
wrong that's okay you have the
opportunity now to grow says the natural
growth of your inner life will
eventually guide you to other insights
but love is what is required in order to
come to know art as such not criticism
towards the end in letter 10 he talks
about half artistic professions and what
would these professions be well he says
that they're the ones that pretend to be
close to art but actually deny and
attack the existence of art we might
think of some great examples of this you
know in the field of heavy metal which
is a you know now quite well recognized
and you know proliferating genre of
music it's become an uber genre with all
of its own little specializations in
turn but if we go back to the classic
heavy metal and you think about some of
the really important bands at the
beginning Black Sabbath deep purple
uriah heep UFO the scorpions Judas
Priest
Motorhead what did the music critics
have to say about these bands this stuff
is garbage it's terrible they said that
about the first Iron Maiden album which
is probably you know one of the most
brilliant pieces of heavy-metal music
that you can find out there it matches
the next five five that that come after
it
and critics somehow missed the boat
on all of that stuff this is just
cacophony noise well it didn't fit what
they wanted their version of art to look
like and we could go over all sorts of
other examples I just picked the ones
I'm most familiar with
so they these are things that talk about
they pretend to be close to art there's
sort of hangers on their satellites
orbiting the genuinely creative types
they have access but they deny and
attack the existence of art they can't
recognize it when it's taking place they
take their cues from other people within
the art world as some you know recent
estheticians have have dubbed it and
they miss out on a lot of really good
art as a result who fits into this group
here's where Elka says some really funny
things he says all of journalism now
you're saying about the journalism of
his time all of journalism does this
journalism oriented towards art and
almost all criticism so he's not saying
that all criticism is necessarily doing
it just almost all of it and he goes on
to say 3/4 of what is called and wants
to be called literature a lot of the
literature is a little bit too art
focused it's not doing its own creative
thing it's merely invoking tropes and
references to and omage ah's and
pastiche --is and all of this sort of
stuff not really providing a genuine
grounded artistic locus of its own so he
goes on and he says avoid these half
artistic professions you know says art
is just a way of living however one
lives one can without knowing prepare
for it
in everything real one is closer to it
more its neighbor than in these unreal
half artistic professions so he's
telling this this this man who's now
doing his military duty service you can
in fact be closer to art than the art
critics then the journalists right
then the literature's who are invoking
it the last thing I want to point out is
there is one section in here in letter 9
where Rilke talks about criticism in a
positive sense but it would be something
that one would do for oneself he talks
about mr. coppices doubt it's vile and
German right which is a you know being
caught between two different things he
says your doubt be can become a good
quality if you train it it must become
knowing it must become criticism he says
ask it whenever it wants to spoil
something for you why something is ugly
demand proofs from a tested you'll find
it perhaps bewildered and embarrassed
perhaps also protesting but don't give
in insist on arguments and act in this
way attentive and persistent every
single time and the day will come when
instead of being a destroyer become one
of your best workers perhaps the most
intelligent of the ones that are
building your life do criticism
differently than all the people who are
paid to or are getting something out of
being critics are doing it do it in such
a way that you actually carry out a
critique of critique it wants to make
arguments it wants to make judgments you
make judgments about it and make it
respond to you and eventually it's going
to become part of you and allow you not
just to be creative but to understand
the creative works of others yet better
but it will be a different kind of
criticism than that of the art critics
won't it it'll be something that has
become a tool a well-honed
sort of doubt so that's real cos views
we notice that art takes an absolute
priority over judgments about it that is
criticism so he's giving this young man
some advice that I think is still
relevant today for all of us who would
like to understand and appreciate works
of art like for example those of Rilke
himself
you